which is a three MPs and Telford yeah
damn for grooming girls yeah English
your people my people the word listens
his word again vulnerable why are they
vulnerable because society didn't care
until bromance tired okay no no what
country did you live in was right so
what you lived in Kuwait yeah
right and you have to cover up your
saying yes okay and you think that's a
indictment on Islam so what you're doing
now is you're putting it on the quickiy
women's do english english reverts to
islam in england covered up women have
free to wear what they like are you
think women should be pretty different
wearing what they like I came here once
were right right you wearing normal
clothes I said I'm wearing this because
I'm pretty good right again but has
nothing to do what we're talking about
we're talking about Islam in England
think I'm a [ __ ] aren't you no yes yeah
but I don't give it okay who he was I
don't know who he was right we're
talking about Islam in England man yeah
forget your anecdotes about what the
Muslim said to you if all of England was
Muslim it would be a fantastic place to
live
[Music]
are you mad you know that tells me you
haven't a clue about Islam
you haven't a clue you think you know
about Islam and I'll be honest with you
if I believed what you believed I would
hate Islam like you forget your blase
what is Sharia law no she realized with
the guidance from God Almighty for his
creation that's what we believe yeah no
problem once I finish with her I can
deal with you it's not a problem okay if
you're reasonable this is why can you
say one country where the I could go to
the example of Islam I've been to
Morocco I loved it there I've been to
Dubai and I've loved it there also I've
been to Oman and that was also fantastic
so you are suggesting I could take you
places in England your hate what's your
point we can all go to bad places
no goes
they're very interesting but I do know
that culture here what culture Islamic
culture tell me about this culture you
show you don't want a culture that takes
care of elderly people when your parents
reach old age you don't want to culture
the taste care of them you want to
counter that abandon them let your
culture yeah would you talk about
grooming gangs sure you might know some
of these people me why would I know
Pakistanis in robaron right just a
stupid statement anyway okay grooming
gangs who are grooming gangs there are
people who prey on vulnerable girls yeah
now you're not going to stop rapists
raping is what they do whether whatever
color they are do you agree with that
okay which is a tree and peas and
telford yeah den for grooming girls yeah
English your people my people of course
is British so we know British Reaper TC
hundred-percent of pedophiles who abused
babies and children are white English
what are the way English to go to
Thailand and Philippines for sex or sex
tourism where's your where's your
campaigning where's your campaigning
why'd you ignore it when a white man
raped somebody who care when a brown man
raped somebody why this is no I tell you
what it's about should I tell you what
it's about I'll tell you I'll give you
one word and this is going to refer to
your the whites going to Philippe's
raping kids and it's going to refer to
Pakistanis or whatever in Reverend
raping kids one word vulnerability
vulnerability do you see middle-class
girls being groomed no do you see
upper-class girls being groomed no it's
always lower-class girls why because
this society has a problem yeah it's
created neglected girls on an industrial
scale
how come 1400 girls be groomed in
Rotherham yeah and nobody cared about
them nobody cares because they came from
a broken family no no no the question is
this this isn't so Kay no here's the
thing she who said it was okay we have a
printer problems help those women
instead of drinking okay first thing how
can I help a girl that her family have
neglected yeah I'm putting it home how
can I help her oh maybe you should just
rape her you know Arnie no no how can
her how can I help her
a small pencil money taking it to rehab
right 1,400 girls in Rotherham English
girls their families threw them to the
streets and they tried to find live
whatever they could were they not were
they not care in care heads but Georgie
listen if I've got I've got a 14 year
old girl yeah I know where she's every
second of the day
how can a 13 year old girl skip school
and go to a hotel with a geezer to drink
alcohol how can the Paras not know where
their daughters are how can you guys
take advantage which Miko's migos
Pakistani okay that's what did I say to
you a rapist walk free listen to me my
rapist you supporting them what listen
to me they're scum I'm not supporting
rapists the scum telling me that the
women the girls has come and the
minister no I said the girls are victims
of neglect and that these scumbags prey
on their vulnerability now this country
has a society problem of neglecting
girls we always had that this is a
reason so we always have that's what we
had care home scandals that's why in
boarding schools here's the key listen
to the words again vulnerability this is
why poor white sari poor Filipino girls
are raped by white English tourists
because they're vulnerable
they don't go to the Philippines to the
rich families give me your daughter they
prey on the one who's vulnerable the
would listens his word again vulnerable
why are they vulnerable because society
didn't care until brown men started
raping them okay why was I great was I
fun durable weave it okay well you were
raped by a grooming gang or by
assembling your family by a very wealthy
Saudi
kidnap man so you saw it was it was a
booming gang offs just someone close to
you right right first thing let's
understand one thing I'm talking about
grooming gangs
I'm talking about preying on a girl
who's vulnerable often are things to
gain her trust and they're using abusing
her yeah now if your rape within a
family construct or something like that
this is a different story it was a
trap I was going out on a date how old
were you 13 13 13 30 yes right now we're
talking about vulnerable girls here not
adult women well I'll give you a
beautiful Islamic okay and I went out on
a date for the normal right long blue
eyed guy and he said I can't take
through the restaurant I have to go to a
business meeting we went to a very big
house right and there are all these men
in white robes so this blond blue-eyed
guy is he Muslim no so you so you were
groomed by an English guy carry on it
was taken to that house he's probably
given a lot of money for this right
right so the English guy groomed you yes
are you blaming Muslims but he grew in
Rosalind news to white in harem there
was two white women complicit in the
grooming I'm going to find vulnerable
girls I know it happens but it shouldn't
happen so wait I'm in some plain blonde
I know you asked us blame society why
are we neglecting these girls that's the
question that needs to be asked nobody
asked that question except me
why does nobody say how can these
thirteen-year-old girls be in hotels
with men drinking alcohol in the middle
of the day when they should be in school
nobody care about them and they sort
love whatever they could yeah
now do you know what solves that problem
that thing you hate Catholicism how does
coffe offices and solve that problem
when we have Catholic priests raping
vulnerable boys which Islam okay it's
LOM is the only religion that can give
you a way of life you'll actually wait
to live your life yeah I don't blame you
walk away I know it stings okay young
lady here was crying about Muslims
taking over her country I pointed out
Marshall last six seven English boys
here masha'allahu big briefs this lump
she couldn't quite fathom it then when
we try to walk we're a hatred of Islam
come from since I've talked about raping
girls or grooming gangs and I've done my
talk about this on the video you've seen
it the question again needs to be asked
these girls are victims there are
victims of rapists scumbags they're
victims of a society neglected them and
they're victims of their own naivety
like it was like I was like I'm sorry
you slum okay okay Isla Silencio Lancia